I'll be very reluctant to give any
stupid spam there are some things that
make make things there the there are men
some of the things we draw on so for
example we know that the biggest
relationship between political
orientation and these personality traits
is between the trade known as openness
to experience and so it turns out that
things like artistic materials a broad
variety of books philosophy original art
the combination of that and a slightly
messy place week so that so that that
would tend to indicate somebody who's
more liberal and conservative especially
when combined with a space that tends to
be more messy then they're less
organized that they're less that they
less punctual they can't find staff
they're no less prepared they're not
thinking before they act and so on and
so if you if you have that combination
that's more likely to be a level
you